I hate that I have to tell you this
today I really do I take no pleasure in
it but at this point it is the
undeniable reality that the Oval Office
and President Trump the executive branch
of the United States government have
been completely subjugated and taken
over by Vladimir Putin and by Russia and
this became unendingly just glaringly
clear yesterday summit in Helsinki
Finland and especially by the absolutely
atrocious and embarrassing and shameful
press conference that was given right
after the private meeting between Trump
and Putin and I struggled today in
planning the segment because it's hard
to know where do you even start with
this and it was yeah I watched the the
press conference it was one of the most
disgusting and vile performances by an
American president in in American
history I would argue and the question
is no longer if Trump is a subordinate
of Putin it's more a question of why has
he become a subordinate of Putin to what
extent is he a captive of the Russians
and how do we fix it that's really the
in thinking pragmatically that's the
number-one question and I admit that I
didn't expect the meeting was going to
go well but the historic low that was
this press conference given by Vladimir
Putin and Donald Trump is as I said of
historic proportions and during the
press conference there was a direct
question about Russian interference in
the 2016 election which at this point is
an undeniable reality we know that
Donald Trump in his answer asked
specifically about do you blame Putin do
you blame the guy or don't you
Trump blamed everyone but the people who
actually did the interfering he blamed
Democrats of course Hillary Clinton why
not the FBI
Robert Muller a witch-hunt investigation
a Pakistani dude but not Vladimir Putin
and Russia and it is one of the most
disgusting acts that I can remember by
an American president certainly during
my lifetime during which I've been
paying attention to politics but it's
actually even worse than I've described
it to you up until this point Donald
Trump went further
said that Putin had a great idea which
was to have Russian officials work with
robert muller on the investigation into
russian meddling russian actors are some
of the perpetrators and Putin says let
me have the perpetrators work with the
investigator and Trump called it quote
an incredible offer from Vladimir Putin
let's go to one of these clips and a lot
of the stuff I just mentioned is in it I
can't even keep track thank you a
question for each president president
Trump you first just now President Putin
denied having anything to do with the
election near Ference in 2016
every US intelligence agency has
concluded that Russia did what who my
first question for you sir is who do you
believe my second question is would you
now with the whole world watching tell
President Putin would you denounce what
happened in 2016 and would you warn him
to never do it again so let me just say
that we have two thoughts you have
groups that are wondering why the FBI
never took the server
why haven't they taken the server why
was the FBI told to leave the office of
the Democratic National Committee I've
been wondering that I've been asking
that for months and months and I've been
tweeting it out and calling it out on
social media where is the server I want
to know where is the server and what is
the server saying with that being said
all I can do is ask the question my
people came to me dan coates came to me
and some others they said they think
it's Russia
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be but I really
do want to see the server but I have I
have confidence in both parties I really
believe that this will probably go on
for a while
but I don't think it can go on without
finding out what happened to the server
what happened to the servers of the
Pakistani gentleman that worked on the
DNC where are those
servers they're missing where are they
what happened to Hillary Clinton's
emails thirty-one thousand emails gone
just gone I think in Russia they
wouldn't be gone so easily I think it's
a disgrace that we can't get Hillary
Clinton's 33,000 emails so I have great
confidence in my intelligence people yet
but I will tell you that President Putin
was extremely strong and powerful in his
denial today and what he did is an
incredible offer
he offered to have the people working on
the case come and work with their
investigators with respect to the 12
people I think that's an incredible
offer so the question is do you blame
Putin do you hold him accountable
everybody knows it was Russia do you
blame him he says the FBI did bad things
the DNC did bad things servers are a
problem Putin said it wasn't him I have
confidence in both Putin and our
intelligence this is gonna go on for a
while
servers are a problem a Pakistani guy is
a problem Hillary's emails are a problem
he praises Russia slams his own
intelligence community he refers to
Putin as strong and powerful and says
Putin has made an incredible offer it's
over it's it's this might as well be the
Constitution of the United States Pat
it's over well when is how do you put it
this into words yeah I don't know if you
really can and I love that part about
you know Putin's going to be in charge
of dealing with Robert Muller and trying
to get to the bottom of all of this it's
kind of like regular story capture in a
way yeah what Trump is doing with all
those executive agencies like let's put
the climate change denier in charge of
the Department of Energy yeah let's put
the Colbert and in charge of you know
the EPA let's put last person you want
to put the mom of an alleged terrorist
in charge of the investigation into the
terrorists why not right I'm sure she'll
have incredibly valuable information to
add about her son this is actually in
line with what Trump wanted all along he
wanted to be in control of the Moller
investigation putting Russia in on the
Moller investigation sort of the next
best thing and the President believes
Vladimir Putin over our own intelligence
agencies this is the perfect response if
you were Putin right if you're Putin and
you're standing there and they go to the
other guy and they say do you hold this
man accountable and Trump says it was
servers a Pakistani Hillary's emails and
this man was just so strong and powerful
and then he says he has no reason to
think that it would be Russia despite
all of our intelligence agencies saying
it with Russia despite all of the other
evidence that we have
he's just says well puttan says it
wasn't them it just wasn't them and of
everybody who has stated an opinion on
this the only person telling the truth
if you believe Donald Trump is Vladimir
Putin the person accused of the actual
wrongdoing so our country has been taken
over we are no longer in control we are
no longer sovereign and the major
question to be answered is why and we
have a poll on our YouTube channel
asking this right now was Trump bribed
was Trump compromised by Russia because
they have really damaging things on him
we're gonna talk about that a little bit
later is Trump just this open to
suggestion like is he this manipulable
or is he doing this because he's being
blackmailed I don't know the answer but
the White House is being subjugated by a
foreign power we suspected it for a
while but the press conference yesterday
has confirmed it beyond any doubt and
I'm increasingly thinking that Putin and
the Russians may indeed have
career-ending dirt on Donald Trump and I
mean not pp tapes I mean something even
worse that I don't even know what it
would be because this is the total
subjugation of a supposed big tough
American president by Vladimir Putin
it's got to be something right because
they receive no criticism ever you know
the European Union their apparent
terrible biggest foe to the United
States can enhance your trade deal
there's Harry though maybe we should
pull out but no he denies election
meddling strong not a single criticism
not a single criticism and this is an
emergency this is it this is an
emergency
red alert this is a man who has to be
removed from office because we have a
president siding with a hostile foreign
power in direct opposition to our own
intelligence community it's traitorous
behavior when we imagined the worst case
scenario this is it and it's a reality
and we have to contend with it now and I
don't know what we do next one of
today's David Pakman show sponsors is
world
crypto con it's a three-day event at the
Aria Resort in Las Vegas from October
31st to November 2nd
this year's theme of world crypto con is
achieving mass adoption of
cryptocurrency and blockchain technology
specifically through small medium and
enterprise business innovation you can
join over 5,000 attendees check out the
150 + exhibitions stretched out over
200,000 square feet of meeting space
enjoy a full schedule of speakers
including many of the biggest names in
the blockchain world and the David
Pakman show audience can get a $300
discount on tickets by using promo code
Pakman at world crypto con-com i've put
a link in the description under the
video once again that is promo code PA
que ma n at world crypto con-com